[Music]
never done anything really stupid with
money
if you have that makes you over 12
almost all of us have my wife Sharon and
I started off with nothing when we first
got married most people do I think and I
started buying and selling real estate
and I got rich by the time I was 26 I
was a millionaire making 250,000 a year
but I'd done stupid
I borrowed too much money bank got sold
to another bank and some Guinan of the
city looked down so there's a kid 26
years old those as millions of dollars
let's limit this relationship which is
banker talk for ruin his life they
called our notes and we spent the next
two and a half years of our life losing
everything we owned we were sued we were
foreclosed on and finally we were
bankrupt I'd do everything backwards I
met God on the way up when I was
becoming wealthy most people meet him at
a point of crisis I met him on the way
up I got to know him on the way down so
twenty-eight years old with a brand-new
baby a toddler and a marriage hanging on
by a thread we got the opportunity to
start from zero again only I had to
figure out how money works not what your
broke brother-in-law's opinion is how
money really works and so as a Christian
I decided I would figure out what the
Bible has to say about money and I
talked to old rich people I didn't want
to talk to young rich people I had been
him I didn't want his opinion in
business we study successful people in a
certain area and then we emulate or copy
what they're doing in order to have the
same success they've had it's called
best practices that's why you hire a
personal trainer they have abs and you
have a keg they know something you don't
know they do something you don't do and
so we learn from someone that knows
something we don't know because they've
actually done it
not have a theory about it see I don't
really care what your theories are about
money if you're broke you're just
arrogant and stupid you live in your
mother's basement you're right a money
blog nobody cares what you think
the rims he doesn't understand the power
of credit cards oh my god really after
30 years you're still writing that stuff
you've got to be kidding me
so we learned how to handle money and we
learned that money really is fairly
simple it's just hard to do there's only
about four or five things you got to do
to win if live on less than you make you
live on a plan written budget you need
to get out of debt because when you
don't have any payments you have money
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income you've got to learn to
save and invest and you can't do that
when you're in debt don't have a plan
and don't live on less than you make you
know why people don't put money in their
401k and their Roth IRAs because they're
gonna need money because it's all going
out the door and stupid but car payments
and Sallie Mae's got our own bedroom at
your house because she's lived there for
so long this is pretty simple stuff guys
it may be primitive it may be easy to
understand but it is very hard to do
because it has everything to do with you
changing your heart and the way you
function in the way you live your life
and you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else because that's the last one there's
a high correlation and all of our data
between people who win with money and
those that are generous generosity is a
key element and people who end up
winning with money and it's pretty
simple it's because generous people are
attractive selfish people aren't they're
ugly attractive people seem to get more
opportunities in life would you agree we
all want to help someone who's
attractive and
talking about physically attractive but
they're likable the person that holds
the door for you versus the one that
customers you for doing it one helps you
pick up your groceries when they're
rolling around the parking lot because
the bottom fell out of your bag that's a
generous person they might be a person
gives you some money because you're
broke you don't have money for food or
you're going through a hard time and
they help you out there's a high
correlation between generosity and
financial success and it's not that
financial success allows people to be
generous it's the generosity causes
people to be people that are loveable
likeable more than selfish people and
they have a tendency a prosper it's
pretty easy formula really if you think
about it and when you're out of debt
the room she doesn't understand the
power of credit cards you out there
watch the power of credit cards destroy
people's lives for years I absolutely
understand the powerful credit card and
I watched stupid people write clickbait
articles about me and other people
saying how to use the credit card the
proper way to use a credit card and
credit cards are good for reward points
yeah I've never met a millionaire that
said Dave you know I made all my money
with airline miles they those Discover
points put me over the top that was my
breakthrough financial moment never met
a single millionaire and I've met with
thousands of millionaires never met one
that said that yeah also I can't believe
people's fault fall for credit card debt
I can't believe people continue to use
these stupid credit cards it's like
somebody the half the population is
dying on lung cancer everybody standing
on going well I guess cigarettes kill
yeah well no kidding
unbelievable the credit card is the
cigarette of the financial world used to
be cool everybody thought it was neat
and people are catching on that ain't a
good idea hello this is not rocket
science people live on less than you
make Becky's on Twitter do you literally
mean beans and rice or is that an
exaggeration to make a point
Becky you've got to be kidding me do you
really think people doing this plant
only live on beans and rice I'm
really twits on twitter really of course
not it means lower you're stupid but
lifestyle and quit spending money like
you're in Congress is what it means it
means quit going out to eat you're broke
it means quit buying the most expensive
thing at whole paycheck over there and
and start white get your dadgum coupons
out and have a meal plan and actually
cook from scratch because it saves money
and don't go on vacation you're broke
and don't buy that you're broke you have
clothes in your closets stay out of the
mall live on less than you make that's
what it means if you live on less than
you make in order to pay off debt in
order to save and invest in order to be
generous you can't spend more than you
make and end up anywhere but in
bankruptcy court and people are doing it
every day everywhere see this stuff we
teach your folks is not hard to
understand it's very hard to actually go
and do it this is the Dave Ramsey show